today we are going to talk about how to
create a modular android application
architecture obviously the first
question we should ask ourselves is why
do we even want to do it and there's a
couple of reasons so you'll quickly go
through them the first one is scale so
if you're writing an application with
you and maybe with your friend like it's
easy it's not going to be too big both
of you can know everything about the
application but as your application
grows you are going to hire more
developers and it will be very hard to
work on the application without stepping
on each other's toes so what you can do
is you can create these modules where
people can specialize in certain
sections of the application and they can
work independently without swimming down
others a similar benefit is
maintainability so if you have a
monolithic application like this where
you have all these layouts and when you
reach to dozens and hundreds of layouts
it's going to be very hard to look at it
and understand what's going on instead
if you group those layouts based on what
feature they're in now it will be so
much easier when you're looking for
something you will find it there it will
never be a long list of mere names and
that has a new added benefit which is
faster incremental compilation so if we
go back to the previous example where
you have this monolithic application on
the left and the motorized application
on the right and we change the same file
in both of these scenarios this is how
much it's going to invalidate this is
how much Gradle needs to do ok check all
of that group run more tasks and those
sites will have more inputs and they
will take longer to run the smaller they
are the faster it is similarly you can
also run your continuous integration
service faster so if you have an
application where we have properly
modulized you know we have some couple
of small modules and there's bigger
modules that depend on them and the
application ATandT depends on all of
them if you made a change in this the
same module 5 which tests do you need to
run to make sure that change is good
this is very simple only that one and
anything else that depends on it this is
the only test you need to run you don't
need to run all of your tests because
the other modules cannot be impacted
well you might say well we don't have
incremental CI many people are in this
situation and it's the same situation
for Android X so this is what we do in
Android X development we wrote a plug-in
that discovers the dependency graph and
then this plugin looks at the git
history figures out which files are
changed which modules include that files
and then discovers which modules are
affected by those changes and then it
only builds the tests for those modules
and our test runner runs only those
tests you can go and check it from this
URL we will add it to the notes and you
can retrofit for your own build before
we did this change our pre-summit in
Android X was taking around two hours
after we made this change it now takes
from 10 to 20 minutes depending on what
you have changed last but not least is
also good for business when you
moisturize your application with
abundance and dynamic delivery we will
talk about it later you can
significantly reduce your install size
from Play Store stats we know that many
of your users drop between the time they
clicked on install to the time they
start using your application so the
smaller your application the less it
takes and you will have just more
signups similarly it also lets you test
different things let's say you have an
application that has a camera feature
and your p.m. comes with this idea I
like I found this amazing library it's
ten megabytes what takes beautiful
photos now you don't need to argue
whether it's good or not you can
implement it as a dynamic the delivered
feature may be tested see if it helps
and then distribute to all of your users
this gives you a lot more flexibility in
trying out different things in your
application without hurting your users
Mochis modules modules you'll be hearing
a lot
this words in this talk so what kind of
modules are we actually talking about
here well we're gonna talk about greater
library modules but also dynamic feature
modules that are part of the android a
bundled packaging concept so let's see
how we define what we put inside a
module how should we motorized so we can
do this either by feature or by layer so
let's start with the feature
motorization let's see what module x
would work for features and also what
are the different options for packaging
that we would have and what are the
implications of these so we would have a
base app that's just an android
application and then we could have a
module that's an android library the app
would depend on this library so this
means that what app would have access to
the code and resources from module one
but the other modules can be dynamic
feature modules and dynamic feature
modules can be used for on-demand code
loading via dynamic delivery and they
would also depend on app so this means
that the module 1 and module 2 would
have access to the code and resources
from app but then I would declare these
modules in in their bid or Gradle file
as dynamic feature modules so what's
important to remember here is that app
doesn't actually depend on module 2 or
module 3 this is actually the main
restriction of the for feature modules
in the app so even if the app doesn't
really have access to the code and
resources
I think this allows the option to have
the on-demand delivery of feature
modules so through dynamic delivery
users can download and install dynamic
features on demand modules that have
on-demand turn off our by default added
as part of your apk of the one that's
downloaded or installed on your device
by the users and if you enable on-demand
delivery it means that you as developers
also need to manage the download of the
module from Google Play Store then
shared code
resources would be part of the core
library and a nice benefit of on-demand
delivered modules is that you can depend
on a third-party library and only
download it when you're actually
downloading that module so this means
that you're able to decrease your apk
size even more okay but how do we decide
what is the dynamic feature module and
what not so for this I like to look at
the 80/20 principle that says that 80%
of your users are using 20% of your app
so look at the other 80% look at those
features that are not part of your core
flow of the app things like expert
features or paid feature features that
can be downloaded later similarly you
can have a feature like onboarding that
can be afterwards uninstalled later
so here the demand on demand will be
false and then you would be able to
clean up a bit of space but how about
something like an about screen this is
something that's not part of the core
flow of the app should this be on-demand
or not should this be a dynamic feature
or not I think rather this is a better
candidate for an Android library because
what you want is to have an instant
access to that Abell screen it's
something small you want to make sure
that you have a good user experience you
don't want the users to wait for this
and also I don't think it's worth having
all the trouble that dynamic features
modules bring for something simple like
about implant one of our sample apps we
took a different approach
so plaid is a newest application it
aggregates data from three different
sources designer use dribble and
producthunt and each of these sources
have their own presentation and business
logic so what we wanted to do is to have
the possibility of on-demand delivery so
we wanted to be able to download these
data sources whenever we need them
wanted to be able to add in the future
others so this means that designer news
and dribble are dynamic feature modules
but then we looked at something like
search and about
wouldn't benefit from on-demand delivery
so we love these as library modules now
let's see how we can motorized per layer
so one option is the Mojo is the
application based on features another
evade simpler option is to use a layered
modulation so what do I have in my days
so let's look at the plate application
again that flora talked about let's look
at what kind of user features we have
and what technologies we need for them
so we said we have stream of memes so we
need a place to persist them we need API
clients to fetch them and we also need a
UI that shows those feeds now we have
multiple news providers so we need
probably different web service clients
we want to have custom styles because we
want the style these needs based on
their source so meet the cost of styling
library and we need authentication
because we want people to be able to
walk on and comment on these stories
which means we also need a posse eye
where people can see the details of a
story and the comments associated with
it so I will take a bottoms-up approach
here we start with the database using
growth I guess it's a good wad and
inside this database module we have our
entities and data access objects and
then we have a web service module on the
site that depends on retrofit and a
jsonparser because all of the api's we
use here use JSON parser we can use
Moshi and it also has data transfer
objects we will talk about them later
now we have our repositories this is
where most of our actual business logic
lives in and now we have things like
user repository or deliver repository
for stuff coming from drivel on top we
have our user interfaces which just talk
to these repositories to display whether
is necessary
last but not least we said we also need
a custom styling library but it can be a
module just by itself because not really
related to our application now let's see
how we can benefit from this kind of
layering
one option is isolation
so there's a little crash course here
when a module says I depend on another
module it can either say API or
implementations now is my know is
confusing so I'm going to quickly
explain them when a module a says I have
an API dependence on module B that means
all of the public functionality provided
by module B is also provided my B so my
dependents can access module B's public
API but if it says it's an
implementation detail then modules that
depend on a cannot see B they shouldn't
know about B and this gives us some
power so let's get a practical example
where we have an API that returns us a
list of comments each comment has some
data inside it and we have a user object
who about who made that comment now if
we want to move this to our database is
going to persist it so we create a
entity as our comment entity inside that
we have an ID we have the text and the
user now if you look at this entity
there's a little problem here because
probably we have the same users
commenting all the time so it's not a
very good idea to keep that information
inside the comment object because like
if a user changes their profile photo
you need to go and update all of them
either option you can do is just create
a user table but then we cannot do it
because our server says the user inside
the comment object there's a very easy
solution for this kind of problems we
can make this a data transfer object a
data transfer object is specifically
designed to get the data from your
back-end to a format that your
application can understand now we can
have a separate object for our database
that will call that one comment and that
one can have the user ID we also have a
user table but now why did we do this
separation let's see how it plays in
practice so go through the scenario our
repository calls the web service to get
the comments we get the list of comment
details than the repository devices into
two it divides them into users and
comments and pushes them back to the
database now let's look at how we
declare the word
fundin sees now our web server says I
have an implementation dependency on
retrofit because the upholstery doesn't
need to know about that it doesn't
matter
similarly database says I'm using room
but no one else needs to know about it
reporter says I'm using the web services
and implementation dependency because UI
doesn't need to know where the data is
coming from but then here we say we have
an API dependency on the database so in
this example we are doing it because
it's very likely that the same object we
are using in the database is what we
also want to use in the UI or like model
might be pulling these objects as
different poles from the database for
our UI so we need to set it as an API
dependency now which is fine but not
that fine because now our user interface
can see the entities we want that but we
don't want our user interfaces to have
access to the database because if they
access the database not we'll loss to
layering because they know where the
data is coming from
they shouldn't that's the theory now
there is two options you can do here you
can define it this you know if someone
writes a code that makes a database
query in the UI layer you know like no
no no you shouldn't do this or you can
take this one step further we could
create another module base for all of
our common value objects that we use
across the application some of those
might be entities some of them might be
just regular value objects and in your
database module you can have other
entities and your doors now the
repository can say I have an API
dependency on this value objects versus
just an implementation dependency on the
database must we do that our UI only has
access to the classes we want it to be
able to access so we get finer control
over them another nice benefit of this
kind of modulation is testing so we said
we have a repositories and we have a
user repository here whoever is writing
user repository can also create a fake
implementation of it a fake
implementation has the same API probably
extends or implements the user interface
but provides additional functionality so
our use
the poster is a good user function I get
user function that returns a live data
or user the fake one has the same
functionality but can have other things
like put this user or put this user as
an error these are the things you will
need when you are trying to write your
UI tests once we have that in our
application we can make the main UI
component depend on the actual
implementation and the test UI component
depend on the fakes this will make it
very easy this is a much better approach
than trying to mock it because when you
mock something you don't know how it is
supposed to behave versus the person who
is writing the repository knows how it
will behave so they can create a much
better fake for you okay
so we looked at how to modernize by
feature and by layer feature
motorisation brings you encapsulation
and the possibility of on-demand
delivery what relation per layer brings
you isolation allows you to isolate your
third-party dependencies or the layers
in your app and also bring structure to
your app but you can also mix and match
apply a feature and layer motorisation
but if you're starting from a monolithic
application I think about the first step
that you could do is to start with a
layer motorisation and then as time goes
by you can go more towards a feature
motorisation so let's see how to work
with dynamic feature modules because
even if this enables on-demand delivery
it also brings a few challenges so the
first one is with navigation so let's
say that our about feature is inside a
dynamic feature module so from our main
activity that's part of app we need to
navigate to this about activity what we
would usually do is just launch an
intent saying I start this about
activity but I said that app doesn't
have a reference to the code from about
so this means that you'll get a compiler
to overcome this what you can do is just
use intent set class name and pass the
component name I know this looks a bit
strange because it's hard-coded and
indeed it means that when you have to
refactor your code you need to make sure
that you're also updating this
drink if you're working with fragments
you have to do something similar you
would have to use reflection to create
an instance of the fragment and with
fragments there is an extra thing that
needs to do you need to make sure that
you also exclude the fragment names from
frog art we know that this is not nice
but in the same time we know that there
are no performance runtime performance
hits for this and we also want to help
improve this process to make navigation
between feature modules as natural as
possible so we are working on this as
part of the navigation jetpack library
okay let's see how we can discover
dependencies in our app let's take the
following example we have a search
activity that is part of the search
module and we want to be able to search
for news in designer news and ripple so
for now let's consider that these two
feature modules designer news and ruble
are already downloaded it's our part of
your app but still designer news dribble
and search are three completely
different modules you don't have
references you don't know how to use how
to call which classes you should call
and we also want to make sure that in
the future if we add another data source
we can easily plug in that one as well
so we kind of want some house search to
define on designer news and treble so
what we do is we use the common core
library that is shared between all of
these so here we're defining the data
source interface and then design a new
century ball implement that interface
and search holds a set of these data
sources so it knows how to query the
data but things were not very easy
because when we want to instantiate the
designer news data source we see that it
depends on other things
it works with a story repository that on
a row works with a remote it a source in
a local data source that also work with
services sure preferences maybe even
room so there are a lot of classes that
you need to instantiate when you want to
create an instance of designer news
datasource so how do we do this in turn
what we actually want is to have one
single entry point for create
but designer news data source see we
would have something like a data source
provider interface that would be fine in
core and I get data source method that
would allow us to retrieve it
and then in designer news we would
implement this data source provider and
then building the dependencies in search
we would need to provide these set of
data sources so we would check whether a
feature is installed and then if it is
we try to get to create an instance via
reflection of that data source provider
and then we get the data source from the
provider and add it to our set of data
sources alternatively you can also do
this via via 8 service loader and you
can check out both versions the
reflection and the service loader in one
of the samples that we release recently
ok so we said that we would need to
create the dependencies and chances are
a lot of you here also using dagger so
let's see how you could do this with
dagger so if you're using bagger you
most like to use another component that
you define in in core so then in in your
designer news data source provider you
would need to create the graph for that
component and then from that graph to
actually get the data source ok so we
said this for the first case our dynamic
feature modules were already installed
but what if they're not what if when
we're launching the search activity we
only have designer news and we want
whenever durable was also installed to
also start searching for data in Drupal
so we start from the same case we'd
still have a data source that's
implemented in designer news and drip
but now having just a set of data
sources is not enough so we also use
live data to make sure that we're also
notifying whatever classes are
interested in these data sources and
then for convenience we wrap this inside
the registry so play core gives us a
possibility to react on modules that
have been
stall so this means that we can register
any listener and then this listener also
tells us when a module was installed so
this is the point where we're getting
the data source is be shown previously
and then we just add it to the registry
now let's see how we work with databases
thank you so when you start moisturizing
your application you're going to face
this problem with databases I'm like
where do I put them and there is no
perfect answer for this so we're going
to go through some examples and options
we can do here so what option is the
easy one you can just have one database
for all of your application which is
what you usually do when you have a
monolithic application or you can create
a core database for the common
functionality and then have separate
databases for your features and they
also have some plans with Roo which are
not ready yet but I'm going to talk
about them because fun so how do we do
it if we have just one database that's
very easy so we have this database
module that depends on rule we put all
of our entities and all of our data is
those objects into that very simple and
then you have modules depending on it
now if you have an architecture like
this the nice thing is it is super
simple to understand you don't need to
guess where I put it you just put it
there and then you have only one
database connection to maintain and then
you can just keep it open for the
duration of your application database
connections are not cheap so if you have
multiple ones you need to be closing
them and this also gives you the
possibility to share tables like if you
have queries that's across modules you
can easily write them in this common
shared database now the problem with
this approach is there is absolutely no
isolation between your modules so
description of a post for one of the
modules might be significantly different
than the other one
so now we need to rename these tables to
make sure they don't conflict I will be
hard when you look at the code base and
even worse they say you use the
dynamically delivered features that flow
in a mesh
now even if you are delivering the
feature dynamically you need to put all
of these entities and data access
objects into this core module that ships
with the app so it creates a like
awkward division between the module with
these entities and the rest of its code
this is something you want okay so let's
go back to the other extreme where we
create the database / module to achieve
the perfect isolation so if these each
database authentication module is on
database feed has on point arrays and
the post is on database if we do that we
reach our goal there is perfect
isolation between all of these modules
but now we have many database
connections that we need to maintain we
cannot keep it open for the duration on
tap anymore we need to start tracking
man we are querying the database and
make sure to close it
mummy are not using it also if you want
to write a query that touches two
different databases
you simply cannot I mean see collide
allows you to attach databases to each
other but there's some difficulties with
that and beside that you will find
yourself implementing C collide in your
own continent code and the one of the
other problems is you will end up
duplicating some data because they will
probably have shared data and you will
just be writing it into both of these
databases of course then obvious
iteration after looking at these three
is why don't we just the hybrid approach
if you go back to this example where we
create the module database for each
module and you look at the feet and the
post databases they probably have the
same data you know the feed shows them
in a list and the post URL shows them as
an individual one with comments so it is
more data but you can basically put all
of them into one database it's not that
you can share the data and it will be a
lot more efficient while we can keep the
authentication just by itself now this
option is great because it gives us full
flexibility but the problem is it's very
flexible so you always find yourself all
right where do I put this one should
they merge these two or should we keep
them separate and you
like going through those decision points
and always a challenge as part of your
application now for room this is an
important problem that we want to solve
similar to how we want to solve the
dynamic library navigation in the
jetpack navigation component wanna
provide support for multi module
applications in room so this is what we
want to do we are going to allow you to
find smaller databases in these modules
in a way that you can let them depend on
each other so room can merge them at
runtime while in your code base you can
get the isolation benefits and then this
way because we know which database
depends on which other database we can
let you create queries in your dos that
query across multiple databases and we
want to support on-demand delivery so
that even if your entities and dolls
look like they're inside the feature
module when it gets installed group will
basically merge them depending on how
you set it up unfortunately it's not
available yet so one thing we haven't
discussed yet is whether these modules
should be android free modules or not
and I think there are advantages and
disadvantages to this so the first thing
is that you could reuse the modules you
could use something like cousin native
and then share that library between
multiple platforms between Android iOS
between mobile and backends oh that's a
great idea
but make sure you have that use case so
if you start like oh let me like remove
all the Android from this codebase so
maybe three years in the future we're
gonna have cross-platform
how do you even know that code is going
to survive three years so don't do it if
you don't have the use case having
Android free modules means that for that
module
we just need to implement a unit tests
that's all we don't need to implement
these Android instrumentation tests that
can be quite slow it's true I don't
disagree but like writing an Android
application that doesn't use the android
framework is a challenge you will find
yourself duplicating things or start
mocking things in your tests so if you
are doing it just for the test
benefits don't just use robolectric and
you can get the same speed benefits
without trying to reinvent android
framework yourself then in general when
you read about our he texture and the
theory around our hip picture in clean
architecture one of the things that you
see one of the guidelines is that you
should minimize dependencies to make
sure that your know depending on classes
that you're not using this also means
that you're able to do a clear
separation of concerns making sure that
your business logic doesn't depend on
any bi classes for example it allows you
to build better ik abstractions
abstractions are great I agree but you
need to be careful just just like as you
add more and more abstractions your
codebase will get more and more
complicated so as you add these
abstractions always think about it like
what benefit am i gaining from this so
the TLDR of this talk is you go back
home after i/o and start rewriting your
application in modules so it's some
responsibility as the Android team to
show you these options but your
responsibility to learn them investigate
see if they work for your use case and
then decide for your use case these are
options these are not rules there's no
like perfect solution that someone
figured out it depends and also you when
you're doing this kind of changes you
should always compare your short-term
costs with your long-term benefits and
make a proper decision speaking of cost
and benefit the modulation or these
abstractions graph usually look like
this so once you start doing like some
modulation maybe the layered one which
which is actually very easy to do you're
going to get a lot of benefits out of it
without spending too much time doing it
but then if your project grows maybe you
can start looking at like moisturizing
my features spend more time in those
that kind of things because you need to
scale the team but then if you are in
the like world of Google's Facebook's
Weavers of the world
we spent out of time those things
because we have hundreds of Engineer
trying to work on the same code base so
it's okay for us to spend this time so
if you're in a similar situation yes go
as far as you can go because you're
gonna gain something but if you're not
in that world don't try to do it because
your users will say oh this application
is very well architected No
no one will ever to pet five-star
comment saying that they're gonna say
things like this is very sleek it's very
robust or this application has great
features I love it so all of these
things we're talking about are a means
to an end we want to have happy
customers not to have more of them so
when you make your architectural or
modulation this is just always keep your
customers and users in your mind thank
you
[Music]